[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh ryan mcgee
very thoughtful writer at espn.com
co-host of marty and mcgee
the sec network and espn radio and
he wrote some things about what's going
on with the sec
and oklahoma texas bigger's not better
here ryan um did the sec have a good
week this past week
the sec had a great week um i mean
listen
you just said it i i co-host the show on
sec network i had a great week i mean
paul feinbaum had a great week you know
a lot of people had
greg sankey had a great week but but the
question is
and this is what i worry about just in
the entirety of sports whenever there's
big changes
is is it good for everyone else and what
made me think of this
interestingly enough was what nick saban
had to say
a few hours before we all found out
through the houston chronicle
for the first time about texas and
oklahoma and he was talking about nil
and he was talking about the transfer
portal and expanded playoff and he said
listen all of these things benefit
alabama
but then he started talking about kent
state where he went to school
and toledo where he was a head coach and
i mean you're a dating guy and
uh jimbo fisher started talking about
samford these
guys worry about how this affects
everyone
not just them but at the end of the day
yeah great for them they said it
but but the question is 10 years now
will this have been great for everyone
if you got an honest answer out of nick
saban and said
are you happy oklahoma and texas are in
the sec
what do you think coach saban would say
nick saban is all about how do i
get to the playoff whether it's four
teams or twelve teams or whatever
it's why every player on his team will
more than likely be
have a shot in their arm a vaccination
by the time they get there
he can't officially say that that's how
it's gonna be nothing's gonna stand in
the way
of him getting to the playoffs so if
this is an obstacle to get to the
playoff
then he ain't happy uh but if if a win
against one of those teams and he
clearly is not scared of anyone
if a win against one of these teams is
what's going to get him to the playoff
then he'll all about it but i think
initially yeah you're looking at the
schedule and you're thinking
okay there's there's a week that i'm
probably not going to play mercer
you know or even schedule miami in the
opener you know this is a week when i've
got one of these two so
i think in the in the short term uh
he will tell you he's happy but he's
probably already trying to do the math
like
what does this mean for me getting to
january right so what's the big picture
what's the end game here for college
football
because i look at greg sankey is roger
goodell
and and espn so those two those two go
hand in hand
but it feels like we're headed towards
the nfl model
in college football where you're going
to have maybe 40
schools you're going to compete for 16
playoff spots
you're going to have conferences you're
going to have
you know usc plays ohio state in week
one
ohio state plays oklahoma and week two
like you're going to have
and you know the smaller schools are
going to be relegated
if you know your history then you know
that you know right across the street
from where the ncaa headquarters used to
be in kansas city is the
is the quaint little building where the
naia lives well they used to run
everything
and then one day uh the big schools
decided to go do something else
and and we've all talked about forever
you know
well at what point do the power five or
whoever the powers that be
go do their own thing because you know
that basketball money was still sitting
over there in indianapolis
and uh you know they were running the
cost ball playoff by themselves
they like the ncaa being the bad guy
even though they were on all the
committees
i mean you know the ncaa the asylum is
run by the inmates
and it was a very very it was very
convenient scapegoat
well now the question is what are they
going to do going forward and i think
you're right i think it's either this
this nfl model which i hate by the way
the nfl is great
but but college is on saturday and the
nfl is on sunday it's why i don't like a
12-team playoff it just feels like
the nfl playoffs it's not different but
going forward it's either going to be
what you're talking about or it's going
to be
what we've all predicted for a long time
which are 16 team super conferences now
whether that's a power 5 or a power 4
i don't know roy kramer the man who
created all this
told me in 2011 he said 14 is not the
number
16 is the number he said once you hit 16
that's the right number of teams more
than that's too many
uh fewer than that's too few that was 10
years ago
and uh you know as per the usual uh roy
kramer seems to be
right what happens with the big ten
i don't you're mr big ten as paul
fondbaum always tells me right
very quiet right yeah and what have we
learned about all this and what did we
learn in 2011 what did we learn in 1992
the people who aren't saying anything
are 100
up to something and uh and so yeah it's
no one at the pac-12 would have said
anything about anything if they hadn't
had media day
just now yeah and so everyone's being
very quiet and
as you know as grain say greg's think
you taught us all a week ago today
uh the quietest person is probably the
person that's up to something
what about notre dame you know
dan to me it all comes down to money i
mean nbc has been writing a check to the
to them for 30 years and it's been great
the question has always been when the
money
gets bigger in the conferences
and you can't ignore it i mean the acc
and i was at the acc championship game
and all those notre dame people like
they're on pretty good time to me you
know
obviously they lost clemson we all
predicted debit but the experience
looked great and coach kelly was telling
me this is great and we're having a
great time
and it was a little it was a tryout and
per the contract
they can't go anywhere until they talk
to the acc first that's what john
swapper wrote in that card that an
amazing contract with notre dame but at
the end of the day
follow the money and if they can make as
much money
with their you know saturday afternoon
and saturday nights on nbc they're going
to stay with that but but if the money
is bigger in a conference
and the payout is bigger in the
conference somewhere so it's the reason
texas and oklahoma are doing what
they're doing
so wherever the checks are bigger well
they'll all end up no matter what to
tell you we're talking to ryan mcgee
espn.com senior writer co-host to marty
and mcgee on sec network and espn radio
we got dale jr on coming up final hour
my man
and i thought he would be interesting to
talk about with just that mental
pressure you know what happened with
simone biles
and i know it's a completely different
sport but
you know getting in that car you know
the pressure he had
he wasn't winning he inherited his dad's
fan base
he got in the car the following week
after you know
senior died at daytona so i'm just kind
of curious
his mindset and you've known junior a
long time
when when i had the incredible honor of
helping dale write his book a few years
ago
racing to the finish he and i both
learned so much about mental health
and we both agreed that whether it was
the loss of his father
or whether it was the loss of my mother
in monroe north carolina around that
same time we both wished
that we had known more about mental
health
when we experienced those things as kids
and
you know his perspective on this is
amazing and it's not just a physical
injury which is what he suffered time
and time and time again
and ultimately pushed him out of the
race car but it was what you're talking
about what we both learned
you know through his doctor and he'll
tell you all about mickey
is that you know stress and
mental health is the greatest
contributing factor to
not being able to heal physical health
and
if you go by as far as you go back now
and listen to what simone biles was
saying
that's what she was saying you know are
you putting yourself in a position
to injure yourself physically perhaps
forever because you weren't in the right
middle mindset and ultimately
uh you know that's the decision that
dell or junior had to make about
his career so yeah i'll be watching and
listening because i
and and then i'm going to call him after
and uh
hey uh i hope you're doing well and uh
i'm good
yeah tell them hey speaking of mental
health you remember that time
in the mid 90s when sportscenter and
this pa turned in a shot sheet and the
handwriting was so atrocious
that it created like a week of firestorm
controversy on campus remember that on
sportscenter
yeah that was that was me yeah yeah and
uh and
uh you you taught me a great lesson
about attitude that week and i have
i've remembered it ever since and
hopefully my attitude
my mental attitude has been better what
was my advice
uh don't be i think it was uh when i
come to you and tell you that your
handwriting is atrocious
uh you probably should be should listen
and and not be so defensive but
in my defense i was 23 years old i think
six months ago i was sitting in western
civic
but yeah i go to driving keith to work
and i go man dan's really mad at me he
goes yes you should listen to what he
says and i did so
thank you for that it worked out well
you know college grad you thought you
knew everything at espn
i did no and i have a 16 year old
daughter now so she knows everything
and uh and i i apply my my dan patrick
lesson to my life here at the house all
the time
wait a minute so you had to pick up
keith from his house and because
i drove to work two or three days a week
yeah my first day as a pa
i walk into the newsroom i've been
watching you guys all throughout college
i walk in the newsroom and keith is
putting
flyers in the mailboxes because the
southington cab company
has increased its rates and he he's
all right so he's looking for a ride to
work and i i didn't even
i still i just come from al jaffe's
office i still have my tie on
and i go are you serious and he said
yeah i said what time did i pick you up
tomorrow so i drove keith to work for
the whole two years i was up there yeah
i'd be like man dan's mad should i
should i be worried he goes yes you
should be worried you should talk to dan
and get the straightened out
okay thank you keith you could write a
book about that
yeah y'all wrote a book yeah and uh yeah
maybe morning i'll write a book when i
write a chapter about driving keith to
work in the time dan patrick uh
had a seminar to talk about my
handwriting but it did
make us better at sportscenter because
of your
your handwriting and your shot sheet
because that's it yeah we were doing
live highlights
it's it's chaos when i tell people we
didn't even get to see what you were
writing
i'd get it on the air live oh yeah and
then i'd have to
kind of figure out your hieroglyphics no
i knew it
so i'm literally running down the
hallway and i you
run 20 steps put the paper on the wall
and write a shot
run 20 steps it just and i could i ran
in there and slide it in there and i
knew i
literally stood in there like this like
this
he can't read gary trent's name what am
i doing here
thankfully thankfully you were good at
it so thank you for that yeah and
then i will take keith to the dry
cleaner and the tcby
[Laughter]
great to talk to you ryan thank you
buddy thank you dan all right
espn.com senior writer co-host of marty
and mcgee on sec network espn radio